[Music]
President Obama's in town did you know
that yeah President Obama is in Los
Angeles today hoping to raise three
million dollars yeah
which may be why I saw him in the right
this morning in the audience line at the
price is right Barack Obama come on down
that's what he should do he should go on
a game show yeah yeah that's the way to
get the dough t-shirt pick me yeah
there's a democratic fundraiser is
offering donors a one-on-one dinner with
President Obama for thirty five thousand
eight hundred dollars yeah you pay that
you get to have dinner with the
president yeah unfortunately the only
person in America who can afford it is
Mitt Romney that's gonna be an awkward
time away yeah just them staring at each
other
there's the sound of plates clinking
yeah what this is crazy Rick Santorum
picked up an endorsement from the lead
singer of the heavy metal band Megadeth
in other words Centrum's the only
candidate who was both pro-life and
Prohm egga death yell I see a mega death
yesterday Oklahoma elected their first
openly gay state senator unfortunately
no no one knows how to break it to the
senator that he's in the state of
Oklahoma not the musical
[Music]
no senator he's gonna be disappointed
he's very sad yeah of course company's
doing all they can to boost profits in
these tough times in a bid to boost
profits Tropicana is adding more water
to their orange juice yeah that explains
their new motto Tropicana
we're like the bartender at Applebee's
that's bad news for Applebee's that
everyone gets that one right away
that's Applebee's for yeah that guy
a new study just came out always a fun
way to start a joke you guys want listen
to a new study
a new study shows that nearly 50% of all
workers think they could do a better job
than their boss yeah yeah yeah the
number jumps to a hundred percent if
their boss is Conan O'Brien well thanks
for having my back
[Laughter]
and what was what's with you nothing
it's just me in the guard at the Gator
having our own show later on
on Twitter yesterday Grammy winner Chris
Brown told his critics to f off yeah in
other words I think he's ready to be in
a relationship again now I gotta I'm
stressed this the man is recuperating
but in Las Vegas a diner suffered a
heart attack while eating at a
restaurant called the Heart Attack Grill
yeah even worse it totally ruined the
man's plans to take his date back to his
room at the chlamydia Hilton you guys
just know the hotel
I like it there it's like it's one of
the best buffets in town yeah
so many ways to take that